parts of yellowstone national park may
be closed for the rest of the summer
season after historic flooding
overwhelmed bridges and roads forcing
more than 10 thousand visitors to be
evacuated some of those trying to escape
the water nearly got hit by falling
rocks scary stuff jonathan vigliotti has
the story of one family who saw their
home get swept away
oh it just moved part of the bank just
slivers just started coming off and we
knew immediately we need to go right now
victoria and tj britton ran out of their
front door monday with a few belongings
and their pets not knowing if they would
ever return within hours they watched
from higher ground as their deck then
garage
then entire home was swallowed by the
rushing waters of the yellowstone river
it's like watching a lot of funerals
i've watched this on tv happen to lots
of other people and when it happens to
you it's devastating officials say it
floated for five miles before sinking
we're lucky it held out until the
morning and we were able to have a
little heads up and get out of there
because otherwise
we would probably be swimming in the
river across montana there are water
rescues as the flooding is stranding
families and isolating communities we've
been spending most of the day today
helping people that have been stranded
the river which carries its way through
yellowstone national park hit historic
water levels after days of rain and
large snow melt
usually a destination for more than 2
million visitors each summer the
sprawling 2.2 million acre park is now
evacuated and completely shut down as
mudslides rocks and raging water tore
through roads and bridges
the park could remain closed for up to a
week and officials say some parts won't
open for a substantial length of time
because of damaged infrastructure
for cbs mornings i'm jonathan vigliotti